and I just remember thinking man the
synergy of marvel and Audi and the way
that it panned out it's just incredible
and then the success of the film and
it's like these two brands built off
each other and it's been a love affair
ever since everyone it's worn here and
Audi just came out with a brand new
promotional video for their new concept
car the Audi e-tron GT featuring Robert
Downey jr. coincidentally the same exact
day that the Avengers end game trailer
dropped in the video he talks about the
relationship between Audi and the Iron
Man films all the way up to Avengers
endgame and in this film it does seem
like Robert Downey jr. has confirmed
that Tony Stark will live and not die
stranded in space alone on the benatar
and be rescued or saved somehow after
the battle on Titan Tony and nebula were
the only two people left and we learned
from the Avengers in game trailer that
they took star-lord ship the benitar and
they left Titan and when they leave they
get lost in space and we know this
because in the trailer Tony Stark
himself says that he ran out of food and
water and that he's about to run out of
oxygen and then there's a scene in the
trailer that looks like it's nebula
touching the shoulder of Tony Stark and
in this scene it looks like Tony is
either dead or dying so everybody
started to wonder is Tony going to live
or is he going to die because this is a
movie about time travel he can die and
easily come back and still be a part of
the majority of the movie but like I
said in this video it sort of seems like
Robert Downey jr. gives it away that he
lives you know I need to drive it right
well I mean I ABS Tony Stark in Avengers
4 out in theaters spring 2019 I did but
this is us now buddy so as you just
heard he says that he has driven this
car as Tony Stark in Avengers 4 well in
Avengers end game Tony will start off on
Titan then he'll leave in the benitar
and get stranded in space so not really
much of an opportunity to drive an Audi
this statement in this video implies
that he of course makes it back to earth
somehow outtie brands their cars in
these movies with Tony Stark they make
it known that they're outie so he's not
going to drive this on some
planet somewhere not to mention this is
a pretty futuristic car it's a concept
car so this could imply that not only
does he live he actually lives sometime
into the future when Tony gets back to
earth it'll be some time not too long
after the snap and I'm not sure what the
world status will be but since half of
the people living on the earth we're
wiped away from existence I'm not sure
if creating new futuristic cars will be
priority number one now he is Tony Stark
so there is a chance that he could
already have the car but when would they
really want to show it what if we don't
see it until the end of the movie until
after Thanos is defeated and everybody
is all happy much like they did with the
first Avengers film well that would mean
that not only would Tony survive being
stranded in outer space but he would
actually survive the attack against
Thanos
I think everybody pretty much believes
that either Tony Stark or Steve Rogers
is going to die in Avengers endgame and
if this statement that he makes in this
video is any kind of a confirmation that
he lives then sorry captain by Robert
Downey jr. saying that he drives this
car in Avengers in game it definitely
confirms that he survives being stranded
in outer space but do you think that
this also confirms that Tony Stark will
survive the battle against Thanos and
Avengers endgame let me know your
thoughts and theories on this in the
comments down below and also let me know
who you think is going to save Tony and
don't forget about my giveaway I'm
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet all you have to do to enter for
your chance to win is to be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero and also
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything related to
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]